This is super interesting, in the last few
days, there have been some tweets floating
around an article saying that the American
right has now gone from the war on Christmas
to the war on Thanksgiving as a sort of replacement
to the nonexistent war on Christmas that they've
been touting for like a decade at this point.
So as a reminder, the war on Christmas is
supposed hostility to Christmas and to Christians,
the right says exists in the United States
by the left.
And it mostly this stems from the idea that
a few years ago there have been since a few
years ago, there have been many people saying,
you know, saying happy holidays is more inclusive
than saying Merry Christmas when you don't
know somebody's religion.
Listen, if you're a Christian and you know
you're talking to a Christian, say, say Merry
Christmas, it might be more inclusive, like
at Starbucks, for example, or maybe at a place
of work or whatever to say happy holidays.
That's it.
That's the genesis and the catalyst for the
so-called war in war on Christmas that the
right has been talking about now for a decade.
We have Thanksgiving coming up here in the
United States during a global pandemic.
And so there are more and more governors and
state public health officials saying you really
shouldn't have large indoor gatherings at
Thanksgiving.
That's how the virus spreads.
And in fact, even at this point in time, most
contagion is happening inside people's homes,
either between family members or friends who
are spending time in close proximity to each
other in indoor spaces.
We know the virus spreads more indoors than
outdoors.
We know that being around someone for hours
rather than minutes is more likely to spread
it.
We're closing in potentially on two hundred
thousand cases per day in a few weeks.
Yesterday, we had 6500 deaths.
So especially with vaccines hopefully coming
soon, it seems this is the time to be careful
rather than reckless.
So the war on Christmas, right wingers have
now taken the opportunity to claim that the
left is waging a war on Thanksgiving.
Here's one short clip.
This is a guy named Charlie Kirch who shockingly
is sometimes promoted by Donald Trump and
others.
Take a look at this.
The left has always hated Thanksgiving.
Thanksgiving.
Can be interpreted as a religious holiday
if you believe in giving thanks to a creator,
but they hate Thanksgiving because they believe
there is nothing you should be thankful for
in America.
This is an awful place.
It is cancerous, rotten to the core.
Tear it all down, burn it from within.
Why would you be thankful?
Instead, we need a revolution.
Remember?
As the Students for a Democratic Society Radicals
once wrote in the 1960s, they said, conflict
is the origin of everything.
What happens when you're thankful?
By definition, you're less likely to be involved
and engaged in conflict.
Thanksgiving is supposed to de-escalate any
sort of preexisting.
Issues.
In our country.
And now they're using the virus as an excuse
for you not to be thankful.
We'll be right back.
Now, Charlie clearly is just upset that he's
still not allowed to sit at the adult table
at Thanksgiving.
They're keeping him at the kids table and
he's just absolutely furious.
But everything he's saying is completely untrue.
The left has never been opposed to being thankful.
The questions about Thanksgiving were never
religious.
They were more about acknowledging that Thanksgiving
has another side to it, just like Columbus
Day, which is the genocide of Native Americans
by early American settlers.
But that's not even the issue here.
What I want to remind you is that the entire
war on Thanksgiving thing is not new there
now.
So the point here is they now are acting as
though this is a fact based reaction to guidelines
around the pandemic.
A year ago, there was no pandemic and they
were still talking about a war on Thanksgiving.
Check this clip out from Fox News last Thanksgiving
more than a year ago.
Prepare their travel plans and dinner menus
for Turkey Day, otherwise known as Thanksgiving.
Cancel culture has turned on the holiday.
And The Huffington Post seriously suggesting
Americans skip spending time with family,
instead forgoing travel to save our planet.
Hillary and comedian Michael Loftis.
Michael, great to see you as always.
Let's put on a screen the title of this article.
It is called The Environmental Impact of Your
Thanksgiving Dinner.
And here's what they want to get rid of.
Q Full screen.
They want to take Turkey out of the turkey
dinner because of your carbon footprint, cut
down on travel for both yourself and your
food.
I'm often interested in my food, travel and
pare down the endless sides and apps.
Now, when I heard this all joking aside, I
got viscerally angry because to me this is
the latest attempt to tear down an American
tradition that was fine and didn't need any
help.
What say you?
Amen, brother.
Cut it out.
That is not a skit.
That is a real segment from Fox News from
last year.
Here is another Fox News segment from last
year.
We've heard about the war on Christmas, but
now college students are declaring a war on
Thanksgiving.
Forget the war on Christmas.
The left is now going after Thanksgiving.
This is Pitts's the war on Thanksgiving.
They want to fight a war on Thanksgiving.
They lost the war on Christmas.
They want to fight again.
PC police while they have a new target.
Thanksgiving canceled culture has turned on
the holiday.
Cancel Thanksgiving dinner.
Very sad to announce we have to cancel Thanksgiving.
All across America, a growing number of students
and professors claim we need to throw away
our turkeys.
No turkey, no traveling.
Cranberry sauce and mashed potatoes are bad
for the planet.
We need to cancel Thanksgiving, cancel Thanksgiving,
telling America America to cancel, cancel
Thanksgiving, cancel Thanksgiving and control
how many kids you have.
I'm not making this up.
So there's a few things going on here.
First of all, money is being made by these
people just creating anger among their followers
for anything.
There's actually lots to be angry about.
We have food lines in Texas this week and
one of the richest countries in the world.
We have a president who has stopped doing
anything as a global 100 year pandemic is
raging.
He's had nothing on his schedule for a week.
We could have health care for everybody, but
we don't like there's no shortage of things
to be mad about, but none of that anger would
be useful to the American right.
So instead, they get people fired up about
these inane nonissues and conspiracy theories.
Joe Biden stole the election.
There's a war on Thanksgiving.
And that is horrifying, but it is a very lucrative
gift for them.
And then the irony of it, if you can call
it that, is that they are actually doing what
they claim the left is doing.
In other words, they say the left wants people
mad about either Christmas or Thanksgiving
or whatever.
That's not true.
They want people mad.
At the left, though, about the non-existent
attacks on Christmas and Thanksgiving that
they claim exists exists.
They are doing what they falsely claim the
left is actually doing.
It's just more projection and it's not going
to stop anytime soon.